già per i salvataggi 40 minuti bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo trovati solidità
del suo testo facendo in fretta però sto
facendo l'inter mentre salgo le scale
sta cosa è alquanto strana erano rimasti
ragazzi che aziona la nostra bella
gnocca anche detta così perché minchia
c'è una pistola che a volte è già una
prima c'è la nostra bellissima mica
gnocca quella lì che sta tipo giocando
quindi ragazzi l'asian perdersi
protonista il suo culo zio tom mancato
adesso ti ho preso ascolta è no no non
mi sto ricordando di non andare fuori
dai [ __ ] perfetto ore che altro
maiali gas e veloce non è arrivata
l'ultima volta perfetto ultima [ __ ]
volta si era fermata prima quindi io
adesso adesso
riprendo il gioco non c'è nel senso
[ __ ]
e vabbè ma dalla sinistra ho capito però
ho colpito è nonno il tuo dentista non è
il mio proprio è diverso ragazzi miss
sorriso 2014 è una cosa stupenda se n'è
andata mi ha fatto che ha garantito
quattro volte almeno per adesso se ne è
andata così
cazzo è quello ragazze un tizio bel mi
piace scusa non volevo ho preso un tizio
che magari mi voleva aiutare quindi non
lo sò io nel dubbio sparo alla gente
ragazza è una cosa che si fa dove è
andato all in a mi piace la [ __ ] di
prima sei molto più gli occhi a di prima
credimi che quello che ucciso primati è
morto stecchito comunque che sono tipo
morti tutti quindi vado avanti spero che
ci sia meno non lo so del gelato
dall'altra parla meno quello forse
l'accesso recensore sa se ne frega le
news un perfetto c'è primi piani nei
ragazzi sta nei condotti se mettessero
delle sbarre e condotti non si muove
guarda che c'è una pistola c'è un tizio
brutti buongiorno ha fatto i capelli
bellissimi la chioma cioè ma che occhi
ciao zio è un robot mi chiami sembra
perfetto sono sono robot suzuki robot a
caso ascolta zio sei un robot
fammi possa da quanto mi inquieta lega è
bruttissimo scalta zio
mi stavi troppo sul culo abbi pazienza
[Musica]
eh ma allora sei un pezzo di mer no non
schiaccia scherza giuro che scherzavo
forchia 3 vabbè ma dio mio non sono
socievoli manco per il premio di roma
pensavo che facesse il deficiente invece
non mi ha preso a calci perfetto allora
l'unico stronzo posso aiutarla simica
devi prenderti una chiave inglese nel
cervello prima non c'era un cristiano in
st nave adesso c'è di tutto privato in
movimento che cazzo me ne faccio di
tracollo si posso giocare a poche monti
del prodotto barra spaziatrice per usare
il levatore di figo può capitare donna
l'ischia affida in tizio tu devi e vita
si va tutto bene stasera
ecco ma tipo se che figata pazzesca
va beh vedo la gente sul rado al
fantastico tua madre non mi piace andare
in sti posti però devo andarci da che
finisco male se no devo contattare
previamente la mia nave per se stesso
riservato non può stare qui dobbiamo
ristabilire le comunicazioni a lungo
raggio fantastico bellissima ascolta
zione non ci provare
finisci ma lo sapevo io che finivi
mareamico lo sapevo che siamo più forti
di quanto pensassi lega sono tipo goku
mio dio
e va bene ma poi ci attrae al ragazzino
non è normale che sti robot facciano
così culo alla gente non è possibile che
al ii impastava dove anche esserci di
mezzo sti stronzi che c'è è pazzesco noi
usciamo che è meglio cos'è
adesso anche le video che fantastica
senti zio e io io te l'ho detto no no no
no no no non ascoltati pezzo di merda
fuori basta cazzo [ __ ] ma perché
regala la sentite non si fanno una mazza
non è possibile
apri apri veloce per oh mio dio mio dio
sono andato ragazzi
sono andato al sicily perfetto devo
andare magari quella po come faceva
arrivare con la porta
cazzo ma porca [ __ ] veloce veloce se
mettiamoci 45 minuti [ __ ] lui ed è
così in capo lo sono agili come mia
nonna questo voglio riconoscessimo che
sorprendere qui non lo so no no no no no
no io ho una seria o una sedia merda
pregare che a noi perché non mi ha preso
non ci posso fare ha via via via via via
via via via via via via via via via via
veloce veloce sono preoccupate
quantomeno puzzano non ci posso credere
a contattare sta minchia di nave che
dati da secoli che tentò di di chiamarla
sarebbe anche più semplici che sto
facendo supplicato tasti a caso
comunicazioni bloccate o chiaro che non
posso chiamare la mia nave fantasma di
una donna l'ansia il suo gioco e non
bastava non bastava veramente allenerò
per le palle giorno ascolta ok ok ok io
negli states faccio pagare ma faccio
pagare tanto è un dio mio dio mio mi sta
seguendo
no no no no no non ci sono il culo c'è
una cuccia nel culo ma qualche pezzo di
merda sei brutto che ai sei brutto non
si trattano così le signore pezzo di
stronzi non ci credo grande grandissimo
pezzo di m
porca [ __ ] cosa ho fatto perché sono
viva savino solivo perfetto io che sono
una donna solo cita liberarmi non si sa
con queste perché sono nel periodo del
ciclo se no core cazzo oggi però di qua
non solo visto che io sto andando a
cazzo da mezz'ora non so neanche dove
sto andando a chi parla sì mi sento che
si è cercato aiuto ma dove siete chi è
che sta parlando
ma quanto cassa cross astana verga il
coro da un ora
cos'è no no no e basta ma che palle
questo cliccato questo cliccato lega
sì sì un filmato di merda un filmato
eravamo preoccupati che sollecita
puntata regionale grazie a dio la
stazione di credito vicino al centro
medico
ok samuel si ascolta qui non è sicuro ma
manco felice ha sincerato questo posto i
suoi android ivan in cielo ad uccidere
gente è impossibile contro i protocolli
programmazione c'è qualcos'altro qui una
creatura grossa e letale problemi
aspetta una creatura una creatura ma una
brutta e cioè che tu non nei confronti e
bellissimi ei rottami la volpina nel
versamento o fatta ragazzi ce l'ho fatta
in un modo incredibile su riuscito a
chiamare la nave adesso ce l'ho fatta a
fare tutto sto casino devo tornare sulla
nave di nuovo il pronome che non
soccorrere può causare incidenti
no no va veloce velocissimo mio dio nel
nuovo visto sentite non ho capito come
come sia possibile che serve come cazzo
sei entrato tu no no no no no ma basta
veloci dove dove devono doveva torna
doveva yoko allora sono andato avanti
per un'ora a caso quindi non ho idea di
governo dove stia andando no però è no
no no no no si si non mi hanno visto no
il calcio invece mai visto non ha visto
non sei serio non aprire non aprire una
prima prima no no no no no no ti prego
ti prego no no no no ma [ __ ] di
stronzo vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
dove fermando dovevate che vado niente
c'è un incrocio nel culo lo presti me
l'hanno presa prova mi fanno male
sistema 28 quasi tutta la vita
[ __ ] salve allora ascolti
caliamoci pezzo di stronzi ha via via
via via uscire di qua produce di qua eh
ma quanti cazzo siete lurido pezzente
tolgono sti stronzi non è possibile a ok
siamo ci siamo ragazzi per intero solo
arrivare alla navetta perché c'è un
cazzo di robot è stato veramente ha solo
adesso che arriva la navetta dovrebbe
dovrebbe essere tutto a posto
secondo me no però vabbè così sono
dettagli da ci siamo che poi non ho
capito perché c'erano robot dove prima
non c'era non a caso non è un robot
questo che abbiamo fatto non ci posso
credere l'ascolto zio e la zia come stai
questa notizia dell'inizio praticamente
lo so che tutto occhi perché ne
approfitti però evitiamo che era tanto
tranquilla fa parte nel nel primo
episodio quindi non dovrebbero scattare
tante parole
come non detto ma questi non sono robot
sono questi a casa ascolta cazzo guardi
grazie zio molto gentile allora fino a
me c'è della gente socievole
non ci posso credere dopo aver passato
il tempo a randellare il cazzo di robot
è un po strano
sono sempre io stare nella merda in sti
giochi per buongiorno salve ascolti
posso prendere questa cosa bellissima
grazie molto gentile lei anche molto
bello messere e stato un piacere grazie
mille o trovare un codice di accesso
sinistra gobbi e casa ci fa zio o
bianche anche in alien isole
scusate io compro una testa nuovo che
hai dovuto uccidere zio bobby però
perché sa che cazzo non mi piace sta
cosa
nori la rilassati una sega no non è
quello che penso è non è quello che per
riga porca [ __ ]
no no no no no no no no no non ho mai
capito ma io lo vedo sul radar non lo
vedo mission iraq e non so
porca [ __ ] ci ha condotto ti ringrazio
dio mio dio abbiamo superato di brutto
che culo assurdo non meno veloce salvare
lo salvare lo salvare lo salvare sia per
i salvataggi 40 minuti ok tua sorece
terzi 6 un figo della madonna chiodo
ragazzi continuerà nel prossimo episodio
comunque è servito è piaciuto ma se il
grosso tuo commento mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook e come noi video
tratta la descrizione se non servirsi di
scrittori ci vediamo il prossimo video
delle ragazze